hi everyone I'm Ilana or char Eliza and
welcome to my channel this thing though
in my face right now that's making the
camera bread you're all red if I do that
is an official saying Scout up from San
Diego comic-con 2013 it was only
produced for San Diego comic-con and was
originally sold in packs of three and I
don't actually know how many of them
there are all I can find online is very
limited or extremely limited so it is
fairly bulky but it's also incredibly
accurate I think that it looks pretty
much exactly as it should it did
originally come in three colors blue
green and red but I obviously got the
red one which is Vegeta's it also makes
the authentic Scout a noise if you press
this button here there's the speaker
that inner box also gave this card so
the idea is that when you look through
the actual red lens or the colored lens
of your Scouter that it's supposed to
show up the power level but I can
actually see it perfectly I don't know
if you guys can see that number there I
can actually see it perfectly without
looking through the scouter so this is
kind of dumb unfortunately isn't size
adjustable but it does flip over and I
found it pretty useful because it's a
little bit low on me normally so if I
just push it up a bit more than it
seemed to fit more correctly they were
actually distributed by bluefin
distribution at comic-con and I think a
pack of three at the actual expo was
about twenty-five dollars but because
they were exclusive to SBCC they have
shot up in price and these are
definitely going to become a collector's
item but I have seen a lot of fan mail
Scouters online and none of them have
ever looked this good so I'm so stoked
to actually be able to own one of these
and you can get them on eBay for around
$200 I think they're going for but aside
from not having a whole lot of uses it
is really really light it's well-made
and I love the noise so these would be
awesome for cosplay and for any Dragon
Ball Z collector's item shelf and it
looks pretty awesome with my collection
thank you guys for watching